c'est qui ça la poule
oui le fait de signer en même temps
qu'on produit le mot va fournir à
l'enfant un moyen supplémentaire de
communiqué donc en général ça va plutôt
favorisé l'émergence du langage on va
signer dans la phrase le mot qui est
porteur de sens un ou deux mots mais on
va pas non
noyer l'enfant sous une tonne de signes
voilà et on va comme on parle en même
temps on ne suit pas la syntaxe de la
langue des signes la langue des signes
française à sa propre syntaxe regarde
les oiseaux ils sont dans leur maison et
quand on signe souvent on va déjà
favoriser la communication parce qu'en
se mettant face à l'enfant
déjà en instaurant le regard et puis en
diminuant un petit peu sa vitesse de
parole parce que quand on signe ça nous
oblige à ralentir
voilà tu veux un gâteau tu voulais
manger tu oublies un gâteau les premiers
signes que les tout-petits s'approprie
ça va plutôt être les signes encore où
bravo évidemment au revoir le gâteau ça
marche très bien
et puis après ça dépend un peu des
habitudes de vie
du vocabulaire qui est utilisé à la
maison à la musique ou encore la musique
il va y avoir aussi ensuite les signes
en lien avec les émotions qui sont assez
utile comme j'ai peur je suis en colère
je suis triste et où j'ai mal des signes
qui vont être quand même assez utile
pour que l'enfant puisse exprimer son
émotion
à un moment où il n'a pas encore les
capacités au niveau verbal un bisou oui
tu les fais un bisou tu fais est-ce que
tu as peur tu as quelqu'un part non t'as
pas peur hein tu as fait un bisou à vous
dis donc
gabriel par exemple la première fois
qu'elle a signé le moment j'ai je
comprenais pas et j'étais en train de la
changer je comprenais pas pourquoi elle
pleurait et d'un coup elle s'est arrêté
de pleurer elle m'a regardé et m'a fait
ce signe est à ce moment là elle pouvait
pas encore prononcé le moment j'ai donc
elle a juste fait le signe et du coup
voilà ça m'a permis de savoir ce qui
n'allait pas oui il pleure quand le mot
n'est pas possible a prononcé pour elle
en général elle va se saisir d'abord du
cygne donc ça ça a démarré dès l'âge de
10 ans 11 mois et commencer à faire ses
premiers signes
et puis souvent le mot va apparaître
ensuite en même temps qu'elle produit le
sil elle va se mettre à dire le mot
et puis en général une fois qu'elle sait
dire le mot belle a plus besoin de
signes un escargot